when we think of all those times in the
past while enjoying round one the crazy
things that have happened it makes you
realize anything can happen
during the nfl draft so that's what
we're going to be picking today now is
the point where you call tails in the
rig coin toss and you get the
opportunity for the first pick in the
draft of the most memorable draft
moments go ahead kristen give me that
tail start this draft week off good for
chris sims
curveball last week and picked heads and
it worked well i know that she was
feeling sorry for you a little uh so i i
i got inside her head on that one and
that's why i knew it was coming up heads
so um okay
i was in the nfl when this one happened
but it's still
to me it's the most memorable moment and
that's going to be the 2004 nfl draft
the eli manning philip rivers new york
giants san diego chargers at the time
you know trade dilemma demand by the
manning family all of that you know for
me at that point come on it was my i'm
going into my second year in the nfl
that was pretty memorable i mean it's
it's it's whoa this is peyton manning's
brother eli he's going to be the number
one pick and you know the mannings of
course are such a stand-up family and so
good in so many ways and all those
things and you're going whoa i wouldn't
expect this family this guy eli who's
been just absolute professional
to be making a demand saying he won't
play for the team that has the number
one pick in the draft the san diego
chargers i thought that was like can't
miss tv and of course i had to i'm
tuning in to watch it because i watch it
anyways but so interested to see if eli
was actually going to go on the stage
and hold the jersey and how that all was
going to play out i mean it's awkward if
you're sitting here watching on tv eli
can barely smile he's like this is weird
i'll hold this jersey and just act like
i'm happy for a second he doesn't want
to hold it i know it's like a little kid
being asked to hold his mother's purse
that was pretty amazing for me that's uh
that's my first pick michael
yeah that that uh
what an image what and he's looking down
at it like do i really have to hold this
thing and here's the thing archie ran
interference for eli eli wanted no part
of the charges he it was him but archie
was the one who took the public flack so
eli wouldn't be disliked or viewed as
he's entitled or spoiled or whatever and
look i get i i'm a big fan of anyone who
pushes back against this entire draft
industry because you know how i feel no
i don't players should be able to pick
where they go it shouldn't be a draft it
should be they draft themselves they
pick their place of employment i love it
when somebody does what eli manning did
i hear you let me just say one more
thing about that whole time period too
because i've been told this by a lot of
nfl people that were you know of course
in the in those type of meetings or in
the draft process that year in 2004 one
of the coolest things i've heard and
i've heard this from many people is in
the draft process leading up to it and
all that this is how
awesome the manning family is the kind
of thinkers they are archie was telling
people
in the scouting
uh you know world and the evaluators he
was going hey don't tell anybody but i
mean eli is better than peyton but don't
don't say that publicly don't say that
he was setting up it behind the scenes
to where i do think he drove up interest
eli even in in more of a way because
when they hear a guy like archie who
doesn't bullcrap or lie or do anything
like that say comments like that they go
oh gosh if archie's saying that he's
better than peyton whoa whoa whoa and i
just thought that was a cool little note
that's that's all i got to say
well that was my first pick too but
since you won the red coin toss you went
with the next pick and this was 20 years
ago and i'll never forget this because
of the run-up to it and all the signals
that were there mike ditka would be a
great guy to play poker with because it
was obvious he wanted ricky williams he
was going to do whatever it took to get
ricky williams and ultimately gave up
the entire 1999 saints draft plus the
first round of the next year to
washington to get ricky williams who
ultimately was a disappointment with new
orleans ditka got fired and the
postscript on all this
all the stuff washington picked up they
got champ bailey they got all those
picks they had back-to-back
first-rounders in the top three the next
year thanks to what the saints didn't do
with ricky williams in 99 washington
never was able to turn that into a good
team that is amazing i mean think about
where washington was 1999 they made it
to the playoffs that year the arrows
pointing up they had the two picks they
did they did we talked about them
recently as to teams that failed to
reach expectations everything was
looking good for them and the first act
was being the recipient of all those
picks when the saints made their move to
get ricky williams yeah i i can't that
would probably have been my next pick
too mike i'm not going to disagree with
you i'll even add to that what made that
even you know
cooler is just as the ricky williams
thing i was going to use this aspect of
it when the philadelphia eagles took
donovan mcnabb over ricky williams and
the fans absolutely booed and went crazy
the eagles fans who thought they were
going to get that was going to be my
ricky that would have been my first pick
if you went eli and philip uh you know
eli manning there but um either way that
was fascinating and ricky williams
let me add one thing to that let me add
one thing that i'm looking at the top
five that year because ricky williams
ended up going five overall that's where
the saints traded up to
one spot before that
the colts took edgar and james
and that was the moment that that that
and that probably set the stage for that
trade when when mike ditka said we're
going up to get him because everybody
thought the colts were going to take
ricky williams and they surprised
everybody by taking edger and james yeah
that was a amazing i can still remember
being on a college visit to the
university of miami butch davis is the
quarter of the coach my dad and i were
there to watch like a spring scrimmage
it wasn't the spring game but it was
spring practice they were having a
scrimmage and they gave the ball the
first play of the skirmish to this
number five up the middle and me and my
dad looked at each other and said man
who the hell is that guy and it was
edgar and james so hey he was in that
class he was a special football player i
mean edgar and james might be a hall of
famer when all said and done so okay
not a bad one by you all right here we
go i'm gonna go with one that's a little
bit before my time but i still think
this is one of the most special draft
moments in the history of the sport and
it goes back to the 1983 draft class i
mean dan marino waiting on the board to
what was what did he end up being pick
number 27 having to wait for five four
quarterbacks in front of him picked i
mean dan marino a guy that was coming at
a pit who had the huge you know sugar
bowl win that year against georgia i
believe if i'm raw uh if i stan if i i
hopefully i got that right is what i'm
trying to say but just act like you
didn't keep going yeah but widely viewed
as of course one of the best
quarterbacks in the draft i guess there
were some rumors about things that went
on you know with him off the field okay
the pittsburgh steelers you look at it
and you think they might take them at
the end of the first round they pass up
on them dan's from pittsburgh that was
shocking but come on the people that
were drafted in front of him okay elway
we know that was fine that was good but
todd blackledge tony eason kenny o'brien
are you kidding me they went before dan
marino
who is one of the five best quarterbacks
in the history of the sport to me that's
one of the most memorable moments and
yeah i was really young but i've seen
plenty of nfl film shows on that one
and tony dungy has told the story
multiple times he told it on chris sims
unbuttoned he told it on pft live he was
an assistant coach with the steelers at
the time and they were worried about
having dan moreno and terry bradshaw at
the same time as it turns out bradshaw
got injured early in the 1983 season and
never played again and his message as as
it was articulated a year ago to the
giants was if there's a quarterback you
like it number two take him don't worry
about eli manning if there's a guy you
think is going to be the guy for the
next 15 years take him and worry later
about figuring out how the the veteran
and the rookie will coexist all right i
am going to go back to and i'm gonna
throw two drafts together chris because
the incidents are too intertwined to
separate 2002 and 2003 minnesota vikings
misadventures with the clock the first
one happened in o2
when the clock had expired in front of
the vikings and the vikings could have
pounced on ryan sims a guy they very
much wanted north carolina defensive
tackle they didn't move fast enough when
the time ran out it turns out the
cowboys and the chiefs were trying to do
a trade the cowboys wanted to move up to
get roy williams they couldn't work it
out the clock expired and before the
vikings could rush to the podium with
the pick for ryan sims the chiefs took
sims the vikings were relegated to
bryant mckinney it all worked out in the
end though because mckinney ended up
being far better than sims but the
vikings really wanted sims a 1m sims not
a 2m sims no relation to chris then the
next year
the vikings trying to trying to do a
deal with i believe the ravens for byron
left which when the vikings were sitting
at number seven
that's when the time expired and
and it all fell apart for the vikings
and they got passed by like two or three
teams before they finally got their pick
in at number 10 i think yeah right
that's right they got kevin williams who
i played against he was from oklahoma
state it was really a who ended up being
great really ended up being great right
he was i mean he hit me a lot in college
i knew he was going to be great um that
was a good that was a good pick i liked
especially that last one with the kevin
williams you know i think you're
disqualified from the draft as of now
it's most memorable draft as in singular
moments not we're going to combine two
years in a row from the team i root for
them screwing up the draft okay we'll
let the people decide yep
for the fifth year in a row nbc has
joined red nose day in america in
support of raising money and awareness
to help children who needs most
campaigns iconic i gotta hold it
together campaigns iconic red noses go
on sale today and are available
exclusively at walgreens and duane
relocations nationwide let's come
together to end child poverty one nose
at a time and put that nose on and make
a colleague laugh boy that's good you
know that's going to live for a while it
should be on a t-shirt i think i've seen
that before in a t i mean i don't know
maybe i'm confused all right let's
continue with the draft the best moments
from the draft on to round three leave
the nose on make your pick it is a great
cause i am happy to be wearing this red
nose i mean anytime you can help out
children there's a lot of them
struggling in the world so i'm happy
about that even though it does make me
sound weird here in this segment because
i can't breathe through my nose okay i'm
gonna go with one that hits home to me
okay
they're gonna go i'm gonna go one uh
that's personal
1979
pick number seven phil sims getting
booed at the draft yeah okay i might
there might be sexier picks out there
but it's most memorable draft moments
and it's my damn draft so i'm picking
this okay but do we have the sound for
this
it's pete rozelle
and it is hilarious because he's got a
great like northeast accent it's
quarterback
from moorhead state quarterback phil
sims and everybody goes boom
so of course that's one of my favorite
draft moments ever i wouldn't be here if
that didn't happen so uh i'm proud of it
and uh of course proud of my dad's
career but yeah he got a lot of crap for
that one and i think a lot of people
were like who the hell is phil sims and
where the hell is moorhead state i think
people still might be asking where the
hell is moorhead state
wait i'm intrigued by this now if they
hadn't taken your dad you would not
exist well i guess
please don't please don't please don't
let me please don't let me you know uh
get too far down that road he came up to
the new york giants
there you go i don't know yeah i don't
know what i'd be or who i'd be or where
i'd be but he met my mom and she
swindled him and now yep they're stuck
together and they had me
all right when when you said this one
hits close to home i thought you were
taking my pick the one that i was
holding for round three but i was a
little nervous that you would because of
maybe some you know simpatico you would
maybe possibly take the pic instead that
would be the moment that unfolded at the
start of the 2016 draft and nobody knew
what the hell was going on when somebody
hacked laramie tunzel's social media
accounts and put up the video of him
with the gas mask bong smoking marijuana
and caused his stock to fall even though
it shouldn't happen it's a shame that it
happened
and it you know it's it's a it's a
warning to everyone out there to make
sure you maintain full control of your
social media accounts because you never
know when someone is going to unleash an
attack on you he lost millions of
dollars because of that when he finally
fell into the laps of the miami dolphins
who will be keeping him around on their
fifth year option and he'll be a guy
who'll be on that team for years to come
he was considered a guy who could go as
high as number one yes and it all fell
apart for him and and i remember that 45
minutes or so of just complete chaos not
knowing what was going on with that
video that just kind of popped up right
before the draft began three years ago
yeah that was pretty crazy actually mike
i'm not gonna lie that kind of slipped
through my memory there i did not even
have that written down so good pull by
you yeah that was pretty crazy you said
it laramie tunzel i think everybody
thought was gonna be
maybe the top pick certainly a top five
pick and then that gets released
unfortunately you go oh geez how far is
he gonna slide what's gonna happen uh i
give credit to the dolphins i believe
that was adam gase that was still there
at the time right when they drafted
tunzell you know for kind of over it was
his second year yeah i don't want to say
overlooking that but being able to know
his first year it was his first year he
just gotten hired right to put that into
context but for them to be able to to
have the guts to deal with the the
public scrutiny on something that really
wasn't fair to judge a guy on but
laramie tunzel uh is a really good
football player one of the better left
tackles the nfl has to offer
other great moments and it's amazing how
many there were the aaron rodgers slide
in 2005. brady quinn in 2009 and he was
so disheveled i feel like his his tie
was twisted sideways his hair was all
messed up and joe theismann called him
out for letting himself get all you know
uh
right while he was back there in the
green room and they've shied away from
having the camera in the guy's face as
he slides now which i think is a good
thing remember geno smith plunged all
the way through round one yeah and
wasn't going to come back for the second
day of the draft when when he ultimately
was uh pick uh early 40-ish or mid-30s
to the jets the year that he came out
from west virginia um marielle williams
going in front of reggie bush and vince
young that was another one i had written
down where i just think that was a
pretty big news at the time because bush
and vince young were such stars already
well and remember what happened reggie
bush was on track to be the first
overall pick that year and that weird
story came out about his family living
rent free a couple of agents that wanted
to represent him and then they blew the
whistle and that that was back when we
actually got bent out of shape when kids
were getting paid by somebody now i say
get paid wherever you can however you
can you should get paid somebody should
be paying you but it was enough to keep
reggie bush from going to the texans
they went mario williams instead so that
was a memorable moment
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports